he's not reading  a presidential daily briefing that has  been dumbed down to one page  mostly pictures graphs and maps get that  son of a [ __ ] off the field right now  out he's fired  he's fired  so in florida  i encourage all to request a ballot and  vote by mail the wind direction shifted  and it sort of split his hair sort of  back to front trump was laughed at by  the entire room of world leaders at the  united nations one of the wettest we've  ever seen from the standpoint of water  then they did dumps they call them dumps  big massive dumps lavar ball is  unaccepting of what i did for his son i  should have left them in jail these  aren't people  these are animals